[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
PAUL SAXMAN: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the Google
Maps Office Hours.
This week is Mars Mania, because
we've been doing a lot
of chatting, a lot of excitement
around the office
about the Curiosity landing.
And we've been looking at
interesting ways that we can
actually integrate that into
our work, because I think
otherwise people got a little
annoyed hearing us talk about
it all the time without
any real--
anything to show for it.
So what we did is we went
through and we thought about
different ways we can actually
use the information and the
imagery that's coming from the
Curiosity Rover and some of
the other imagery that's
available from Mars and do
interesting things with
the Google Maps API.
So we've done two things
for this week.
And there's a lot of other
things that we've been playing
around with, and we might be
able to show at a future day.
One is, actually, we did a
Street View imagery of the
panoramas that we got from the
Curiosity Rover, or the
panorama that we got from NASA
of the Curiosity Rover.
And the other one is actually
looking at some of the
elevation data that we got
from one of the other
satellites.
Which one was that?
That was the--
BRENDAN KENNY: The Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, the MRO,
and seeing if we could do,
actually, elevation analysis
using the Google Maps APIs.
And we didn't introduce--
I think everybody knows you
at this point, Brendan.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
Hi, I'm Brendan Kenny.
PAUL SAXMAN: So Brendan's been
working on the elevation data.
I've been working on
the Street View.
And a quick couple logistic
things real quick.
Usually, we set up a moderator
so that people can actually
submit comments.
We didn't do this this week,
because we found that people
were putting comments pretty
much all over the place,
either on YouTube, or on
Google+, or in Moderator.
So if you have any questions
and you want us to look at
them, either today or after the
session, either put them
on the YouTube or Google+, and
we're going to take a look at
those a little bit later.
So in terms of Street View, I
guess we'll start with what we
did with Street View.
So basically what NASA did is
they did a stitching of some
images that they took from the
Curiosity Rover, and they made
a complete 360-degree
panorama.
And with that panorama, what
we're able to do is actually
put that into the Street View
service to actually look at
that as we would Street View.
Just as Street View itself, it's
not super interesting.
You can just pan around and zoom
in and out of the image.
But what's really curious is
when you can layer things on
top of that.
So what we're going to do today
is I'll show you what we
did to get the imagery
into Street View.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about some of the extra
stuff that you can add on.
And then in terms of the--
what were you going to like to
talk about today with the--
BRENDAN KENNY: I think just
take a look at taking the
imagery, which is in kind of
a weird format, and just
bringing it in in a format that
we can use easily, and
then just importing it
and using WebGL to
display it in real time.
Unfortunately, the really
high-res imagery of where the
Curiosity lander is right now
is not coming for two days.
So we timed our Hangout
two days early.
But we do have lots of other
imagery of Mars that we're
able to take a look at.
And then hopefully, in
two days, we'll be
able to post the--
I think it's down to 24
centimeters per pixel
resolution of the landing area
in terms of elevation.
They've already published
imagery itself of the area.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So this Mars mission, really,
there's a lot of imagery
coming out just because--
BRENDAN KENNY: Tons.
PAUL SAXMAN: They've had a lot
of really good cameras on the
rover and the satellites both.
And so it's a great
opportunity to
play around with it.
And there's actually been other
people that have been
looking at this as well.
We saw recently there's--
I'm going to forget the website
off the top of my
head-- but somebody actually did
a panorama very similar to
what we're going to show
in Street View, but
a little bit different.
It's not using Street
View technology.
So why don't we kick off.
We'll show you--
well, actually, let's cover a
little bit about the imagery.
So the image that we got from
NASA is actually rather large.
It's about 30,000 by--
I think it was about 4,000 or
so pixels, so it's a very
high-resolution image.
It's a composite of quite
a few images.
Like I said, they stitched
them together.
And what we did is, to get it in
the Street View imagery, we
actually expanded it
out horizontally--
I'm sorry, vertically--
to include some kind
of letter boxing.
And that just allows us to put
it in a two-by-one format.
And what I can do right now--
so I'm going to show you on
the screen here--
that's not the one I want.
So this is what the original
image looks like.
This is zoomed out pretty far.
You've probably all seen this
if you've been following the
Curiosity mission.
And this is a very--
like I said, a very
high-resolution image.
It's about 30,000 pixels wide.
So you can see, as we zoom in,
it actually maintains quality
quite far in.
You can actually see pretty
good detail on even these
rocks that are in the
far distance.
BRENDAN KENNY: You can see why
I started naming the rocks.
PAUL SAXMAN: Ah, yeah.
BRENDAN KENNY: Because this is
all you have to look at.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, we have names
for rocks, and we have
names for the scorch marks.
We've pretty much--
I was looking, actually, for
names of some of the other--
like the mountains in the
distance, and I didn't find
any that were necessarily
correlated to this image yet.
But if anybody has any--
BRENDAN KENNY: Well, the
big one is Mount Sharp.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep.
BRENDAN KENNY: And then there's
a much better name
that's a Greek--
something about wind, but I
don't remember what it is.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, Gaelus?
BRENDAN KENNY: Nah.
It's the other one.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, I gotcha.
BRENDAN KENNY: Anyway.
PAUL SAXMAN: So like I said,
what we do with this image,
since this obviously is in a
two-to-one aspect ratio, it's
actually quite a bit longer
than it is high.
We actually padded it
out to make it a
two-to-one aspect ratio.
And this is what it
looks like here.
The reason we did that is,
actually, it's a lot easier to
manipulate in when we were doing
the tiling and actually
setting things up for
the Street View.
You don't have to.
You can actually go.
You could actually tile
up the original image.
But you're just going to have
to be careful, because since
it's not in an even aspect
ratio, you might end up with
odd-sized tiles.
Or the tiles might actually
overlap if you don't get the
calculations right.
Or you might not have enough
image to fill in the entire
tile around the edges.
So we padded it out.
And it just so happens that
the 29,184 is the actual
length of the image.
It's very easily divisible by
16, so that ends up being
about 1,824 or 2,000 pixels.
So we took that.
The reason we took 16--
OK, well, let's take
a step back.
And with the Street View,
the way it works is--
let's just go to the image and
show you what it looks like.
It's a lot easier.
So here's, actually,
that same image,
actually, in Street View.
You see a couple markers here,
which we'll talk about in a
little bit.
But you can see, this is
actually just like Street View
you'd see with--
on the Google Maps product or
you can do with any other
panoramic images.
And what we did--
so like I said, we put this in
Street View, and we tiled it
up, so actually, it can maintain
the resolution of the
image or the quality
of the image.
So we couldn't just take the
30,000-pixel by 15,000-pixel
two-to-one aspect ratio image
that we produced and drop it
directly into Street View.
We had to tile it up.
And tiling is the same process
that you use for Maps.
So as you zoom in, instead of
actually zooming in that
entire image and scaling that
entire image, what it'll do is
it'll just load what tiles
are relevant for the
current view port.
And you can see by
doing that--
can't find the exact rock we
were looking at earlier, but
we'll find another one.
There's plenty of
rocks out there.
As we zoom in, you can see
that we actually are
maintaining pretty much the same
quality that we had with
the original image.
And that's just because we are
able to-- what we did is we
tiled it up, and we made it a
little more efficient for the
system to actually deal
with the images.
BRENDAN KENNY: Can you scroll
down to the scorch mark?
PAUL SAXMAN: The scorch mark?
You want to see the--
BRENDAN KENNY: It's
pretty cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think these ones
definitely have names.
I can't remember all of them.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, we should
have written those down.
PAUL SAXMAN: I have a couple
of them, the names, as what
the markers were earlier.
So what I'll show you first
is the code that I used,
actually, to do the tiling.
So originally, I
tried to use--
there's GDAL.
It's actually a tool, an
open-source tool, for actually
doing Maps tiles.
And I ran into a little bit of
difficulty, actually, getting
that running on a Mac.
I put it on a Linux workstation
instead.
I ran it there.
Everything seemed to work fine,
but I had a little bit
of trouble getting the
images looking right.
So what I did is I just
defaulted back to Bash
scripting and using ImageMagick
to do the tiling.
So what I did for the
tiling is I'm taking
the original image.
So that's our full size, what
we call in the Maps, the
Street View API, the World.
So I'm cropping the
entire image, so
that's our maximum zoom.
And I'm doing that at 16-by-16
tiles, which ends up about
2,000-by-900 pixels per tile at
2-to-1 aspect ratio tiles.
So they're not square tiles.
And then for the other zoom
level, so as you're zoomed out
from the full zoom, I'm just
dividing by two each time.
So the next resolution
is 8 by 8.
And I didn't--
actually, I did write
that down.
8 by 8 is about 4,000-by-2,000
pixels.
4 by 4 is about 2,000-by-1,000
pixels, and then 2 by 2,
1,000-by-512.
And actually, we'll do all the
way back to zero zoom, which
is 512 by 256.
So the first thing I'm doing
is I'm actually producing--
taking that original image and
actually scaling it to all of
those individual resolutions for
the different zoom levels
and then tiling up those using
the constant tile size of
1,824 by 912.
So if I look at the code again--
so here, basically,
I'm saying Taking File Input,
Identifying the--
let me zoom that in a little
bit more so hopefully
everybody can read it, getting
My Tools in Shape.
I'll come back to this in a
minute, the MPC file format,
which is something specific
to image management.
Very useful, and I'll talk
about that in a minute.
Here, I'm specifying
my zoom levels, the
maximum number of tiles.
That's for the full-size
image.
I use that information
a little bit later.
I'm getting the full-image
resolution out using the
Identify command, which is
ImageMagick tool, and
calculating the tile widths
and heights based on the
full-size image and the
maximum zoom level.
And then what I'm doing is I'm
just looping through the zoom
levels that I want.
So I'm going to go from zero
to four zoom levels.
And there's a really interesting
thing to note
about the zoom levels, that
the zoom levels don't
necessarily correspond to the
controls on the Street View.
So the Street View controls can
have zoom levels from--
I don't know what it is.
I think it's maybe about six
different zoom levels.
But what the API does, it
actually optimizes.
So if you have a really small
view port, it can actually use
a higher zoom level
for the tiles.
So it's a little
counterintuitive, but if you
play around with this a little
bit, you'll eventually see
what it's doing.
So I'm going through each of
the different zoom levels.
I'm calculating the width and
height for the image for that
zoom level, the full-size image
for that zoom level, and
I'm calculating the number of
tiles that I'm going to need
for that zoom level.
And since I do have 2-to-1 ratio
tiles and 2-to-1 ratio
image, I can just use the same
number of tiles horizontally
and vertically.
And then I'm doing
a conversion.
And what this conversion is
doing is taking that original
TIFF image, which is really
uncompressed, rather large,
and pretty hard to deal with
actually in terms of doing
cropping and tiling.
I'm converting it to the scaled
image but using the MPC
format for ImageMagick.
And like I said, that MPC
format, what it does is it
allows you to--
it's an optimized format for
ImageMagick so that they can
actually index pixels as opposed
to actually having to
uncompress the original TIFF
and work back from there.
So it makes the actual
conversion a lot quicker.
Before I was using MPC--
I didn't know about
it originally--
the conversion was taking-- or
actually, doing all the tiling
for zero-to-four zoom levels, it
was taking maybe about half
an hour or more.
Or actually, I think
it was even longer.
I think we went to lunch.
It was maybe more
than an hour.
With the MPC format doing the
four zoom levels, it's pretty
straightforward.
And then I'm actually doing
the tiling, so I'm going
vertically, horizontally.
And I'm just sampling out or
cropping out different tiles
and saving those to files.
In the HTML code--
I'm going to switch over
to here real quick--
this is actually going to look a
lot like some of the samples
we have for Street View.
I've pretty much just
picked those out.
The big differences here is
what you do is you specify
Custom Tile URLs.
And this is actually something
that you specify when you set
up the Street View options.
I think it's way up here.
No, I'm sorry.
So when you set up the panorama
options, you specify
the Panorama Provider.
And the Panorama Provider
actually includes the method
for getting the custom
tiles out.
So you can have multiple tiles
or multiple panoramas in one
display, and the same
code can be reused.
And what I did here is I'm just
saying that I want to use
tile with a particular zoom
level, the Tile X and Tile Y.
If we go down here, this--
I didn't find this
superintuitive at first, but
the World Size is actually
Original Image Size or the
full-size image, and
then you have to
specify your tile size.
And this is how the Street View
API actually optimizes,
so pretty straightforward.
The other stuff that I
can show up here--
BRENDAN KENNY: It did show
us your markers.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep.
So let me-- we'll go back to the
actual Street View that I
showed you before.
So these are kind of fun, and
this is stuff that I was
working on pretty
much yesterday.
But since this is Street View,
some of the advanced features
that you can add over just a
standard image viewing tool is
that we can add markers
on the display.
And these markers, they look
really small, and I'll talk
about why that is in a second.
But you can add markers
to the display.
You can add info windows, and I
think you can also do custom
overlays or overlays on
top of this as well.
I think we showed a couple weeks
ago, Brendan, you had
that overlay view with the
three-dimensional stuff in there.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, well, that's a very
custom overlay.
But it's nice, because if you
have your map content--
I mean, if you've ever used the
streaming API before, and
then you switch to the
Street View, the
same content is there.
We just don't have an overhead
view of Mars.
I guess we could've made one.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, right.
BRENDAN KENNY: What is Burn--
do you know what Burnside
Scour is named for?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, that's
a good question.
BRENDAN KENNY: I'm going
to look that up.
PAUL SAXMAN: I'm going to assume
it's somebody's name,
because this one, I think, is
called-- the one on the right
is called--
I feel like I should
know this--
Goulburn Scour.
And actually, there's
two other scours
on the other side.
BRENDAN KENNY: Are they
both named burn?
Is that--
PAUL SAXMAN: No, no.
BRENDAN KENNY: --like a
joke, do you think?
Because it's like a rocket?
Never mind.
PAUL SAXMAN: So another thing
that's kind of fun with these
markers, these are just map
markers, so you can do things.
I mean, they can be animated.
I didn't animate them, because
the animation is a little
funny here, because
they are actually
zoomed pretty far out.
But you can actually make
them draggable.
And this is why they're actually
pretty small, because
they're pretty far out, or
the scour is actually
relatively far out.
So these markers, you could
make them draggable.
You can move them around.
And this is actually how I
identified the latitude and
longitude, where
to mark these.
Because the latitude--
I have the latitude and
longitude for actually where
the lander landed, but I didn't
have the latitude and
longitude for the scours.
Data's probably out there
somewhere, but--
so yeah.
So you can put the
markers on here.
And so the other thing that we
can do in the future with this
is as we do get more imagery,
we can actually
do the Street View--
what do you call that
when you're moving
from panorama to panorama?
So if we have multiple
panoramas, we can actually
say, well, this is the
route to the rover.
You can follow the route, and
every time it takes a
panorama, we can put that
in here as well.
I don't know if we'll--
BRENDAN KENNY: I really want
to do that, so yeah.
I might not one day when there's
thousands of them I
might not do it.
But I want to do it
at least once.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
BRENDAN KENNY: Or a few times.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think it
would be a lot of fun.
BRENDAN KENNY: I'm not
sure when it's
supposed to start rolling.
I think it's actually started
moving a little bit, but it's
mostly just moving in place
while they figure out all the
wheels and the motor
situation.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
And I did just see there is, I
think, another black-and-white
panorama that came out
very recently.
So the panoramas are going
to keep coming.
Oh, they also have
the deck imagery.
You could stitch together
quite a bit more.
With the deck imagery,
I think that's how--
I was mentioning before that
somebody actually did a
full-view panorama.
And what they did is they
actually simulated the sky, so
they did simulated sky
up on the top.
And then I think they also took
the deck imagery, and
they put the deck imagery
along the bottom.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, right.
Yeah, I found that
a little strange.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I mean, it was--
BRENDAN KENNY: Well, there was
just a lot of simulated
imagery, and it was-- nah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think from a artistic
standpoint, I think
it was a really, really
great thing.
And I mean, it is kind
of an immersive--
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: Immersive feel.
So one thing that I found and
I've been toying around with a
lot with the Street View API is
that the bigger this window
gets, the performance actually
degrades somewhat.
So that's one thing you really
want to keep aware of.
And what I actually tried
is multiple--
tried to use multiple different
tile sizes.
I tried to make the tiles really
small or actually blow
them up quite large.
The performance hit was
always there as I made
the View Port larger.
So good View Port size I found
about 1,024 by 768.
This one, I think, might
be about 800 by 600.
BRENDAN KENNY: And it varies
somewhat by platform.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, that, too.
BRENDAN KENNY: Because some
browsers have accelerated
canvas, and so you get
super-smooth performance.
And then some browsers rely on
the what's called HTML4 mode,
where it's just displaying
the tiles directly.
And so it might be a
little bit slower.
And until all the browsers
catch up to more modern
techniques of drawing things,
then we're going to have that
kind of spread in performance.
But it is nice.
And I think the thing I want to
most emphasize with this is
how easy it is to do a
Custom Street View.
I think with going into it and
making a bunch of tiles, it
does become a little
bit harder, a
little bit more work.
But it's actually not
very much work.
And it's a skill, especially if
you want to get into more
complicated mapping
applications.
Like being able to make tiles at
the drop of a hat is a very
important skill.
And so it's a valuable
thing to invest your
time in and to learn.
But once you have those
tiles, it's really--
it's dead simple.
The API is very simple.
Actually, I think it's one
of the more elegant
parts of our API.
And at that point, you can have
all the custom panoramas
you can think of.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So we'll post--
a lot of the code that I got--
the Bash script that I put
together was actually pulled
together from some sources
on Stack Overflow.
The trick with using the MPC
files actually was a trick I
found on Stack Overflow.
We'll either post the code out
on Stack Overflow or maybe in
the Google+ following up
so that you guys can
take a look at it.
So what--
BRENDAN KENNY: I don't know if
I'd be brave enough to post
one of my Bash scripts.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Bash is kind of an art form when
you're doing more complex
scripting, I think, but
entirely useful.
So I'm passing the
laptop over.
So in the next few minutes,
we're going to--
Brendan's going to switch over
and show some of the elevation
work that he's been doing,
which is actually pretty
amazing stuff as well.
BRENDAN KENNY: See if we can--
there we go.
So the data I'm using comes from
the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter, as I said earlier.
And so it's been circling Mars
for several years now.
And one of the most
helpful ways--
or one of the most important
things it's doing is actually
relaying information from
Curiosity to Earth.
But it also has some really nice
cameras, and one of them
is the high-rise camera.
And-- oh, this is
reverse scroll.
And let's see.
I'll just pick one randomly.
And so it has super-high
resolution.
It flies fairly low over Mars,
and it has an extremely high
resolution--
I don't know-- capturing
apparatus.
I think it's actually--
technically, it's a telescope.
And so what it does is it's
called stereophotogrammetry,
which is the same technique
that people use from
everything from our new 3D
helicopter view in Earth on
mobile to things where you take
multiple pictures, and
you can extract a point cloud
and a 3D model out of that.
And basically, what you do is
you use information about
where the camera was from
multiple viewpoints, identify
objects that are the same in
each, and then basically
triangulate from each of those
photos to figure out where
things are in 3D space.
It's the same thing our eyes
do with binocular vision.
So the satellite does that by
actually taking multiple
passes over Mars.
So it goes over once, and then
a few days later, or a month
later, or something, it goes
over the same area from a
slightly different angle.
And from that, they
can extract pretty
high-resolution, as I said, I
think down to 24 centimeters
per pixel elevation maps.
And unfortunately, they just
took one, I think, about three
or four days ago of the
Curiosity area.
You might have seen it.
It had exaggerated color with
blue instead of gray.
And so in two more days, they're
going to take another
pass and have a really
high-resolution view of the area.
But we don't have that, so I
just picked a random area.
And you can see the format
they have here.
Here's a version that
turns the-- nope,
that's not what I want.
Color altimetry.
Here's a version that turns
that altitude into color.
So part of the problem
is that usually the
elevation data is--
it needs more precision than the
8 bits per pixel that you
usually have in a grayscale
picture.
So here you can tell--
we have a scale down
here at the bottom.
This varies over almost
1 and 1/2 kilometers.
And so you only have 256 levels
in a byte, and so you
actually need more than that.
And so sometimes it's
16 bits or whatever.
And so this is one way
of displaying it.
They just map it to a color
ramp, and you can see down
here is the really low areas
and the high areas.
And there's a bunch of formats
that they provide.
It's extremely helpful.
And if you look into it, it's
called a PDS format, which I'd
never heard of, and
it seemed obscure.
And I couldn't find much on it,
and Google was trying to
convince me that I was
looking for a PSD.
But it turns out it's extremely
common in the GIS
world, and so what do I know.
And so GDAL supports it.
And so you can use
gdal_translate to translate
from the PDS or ING format
over to basically
anything you want.
And so it's a little bit tricky,
because WebGL right
now only supports
8-bit-per-channel images.
And so, really, what you want
to do is maybe pack into
different color channels.
But for now we can just go
with a lower-res 8-bit
grayscale image and
deal with that.
So what's the best
way to show this?
So first you translate it into
a grayscale, and it looks a
lot like this.
And then we use what's
called--
well, the simplest way is to
use something that's like
finite differencing, which is a
way of measuring the rate of
change over pixels.
And it sounds really fancy,
and lots of people try and
trick you and think
that it's fancy.
But it's not really.
It's just subtraction.
It's very common, like, oh,
yeah, I got my whatever degree
in finite differencing models
and modeling airflow over cars
or something like that.
It's just subtraction where
you're looking at the
difference between two discrete
samples, like pixels,
and looking at the angle as
it changes between them.
And that's all a change in
elevation is, is the change in
heights of this thing.
And from that you can
figure out the
direction of a surface.
So now we have a surface
like this.
And so then if we have a light
ray coming in this way, and
the direction of the surface
is that way, that surface
might be kind of dark.
But if it's coming in
directly at the
surface, it might be lighter.
And that's pretty
much how we--
that's the 30-second "cause
already over time" display.
So there are fancier
things you can do.
So one of the problems is that
just like with Maps, you have
to pull in a tile for
every one of these--
I don't know, a tile for
every unit of area.
And if you want to pull in more
data, you have to fit
into that RGBA channels.
And if you want to get in even
more data, you're going to
pull in another tile,
and every tile's
going to slow you down.
So you start figuring out ways
to pack in information into
these tiles.
And fortunately, game developers
are way ahead of
us, because they've been dealing
with small CDs, and
then DVDs, and downloadable
games for years now.
And so they have lots
of tricky ways.
And one of the ways I use is to
pack that surface normal,
which is really a 3D vector,
into two components.
And so you just have the R and
G channels used for that, and
then you still have your blue
and your alpha for whatever
you want, like you can bring
in other fancy data.
And it's not that interesting.
It's pretty much the observation
that a sphere is a
surface in 3D, but it's also
we can describe it with two
dimensions, like latitude
and longitude.
And latitude and longitude are
inefficient, because you waste
a lot of precision
at the poles.
So you can actually spread it
back out, and it basically
ends up being a reflection in
a parabolic dish, which is
kind of fun.
So if we go over here to the
demo itself, it's less
exciting after all
that buildup.
But here is an area--
and I only extracted like two
zoom levels, and it's somewhat
low resolution, as I said.
But here we have some really
cool sand dunes on Mars, and
it goes into some
rocks over here.
And I think-- oh, wait.
No, only two zoom levels.
Wait.
There we go.
You can see pretty
much that's--
and then there we have it.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you actually
did the lighting?
I mean, you took the--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
So the lighting is in here.
Unfortunately, to enable
it-- we're out of time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, no worries.
Yeah, so the idea is really that
with the elevation data,
you can actually--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, you can
light it in real time.
And actually, a really cool idea
would've been the heat
shield landing and
being like--
we're going to do that.
Maybe we'll do that
this afternoon.
But I guess it didn't explode.
But we can imagine it's like a
Michael Bay universe that--
well, I can imagine.
PAUL SAXMAN: What we're looking
at here, though, is so
you took the elevation data that
was in the RGB channels,
and then you actually did-- so
where did you actually plot
the lighting in this one?
BRENDAN KENNY: So if we look--
I don't know if we
really want to--
here's the actual shaders
that I'm using.
So if you're familiar
with WebGL, this
shouldn't be a big deal.
If you're not, it's
not a big deal.
It's just a different language
that's ideally
suited for this stuff.
It won't let me scroll.
It still won't let me scroll.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you took those
images You loaded them in
there, and now you're--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
So let's see.
So here's where I get the
normal, which is just the
surface direction.
And so the actual--
well, the lighting is a little
complicated, because I do some
fancy lighting.
But it's pretty much this,
where we take a light
direction, and this comes in
from the mouse direction,
which is what I would enable
if we had a moment.
But in the end, I just take
the light direction, and I
take the normal, and I
dot-product them together,
which gives me the angle
between them.
And then I attenuate
that by the view.
So if you get this angle,
that would be specular.
But it's pointing away from
you, you'd get less light.
So you can do quite complicated
things in here.
It's just up to you
to imagine them.
And I think it'd be great
to eventually show--
there's no reason why you have
to limit yourself to imagery.
You can start looking at turning
this into geometry and
doing some interesting things.
PAUL SAXMAN: So this is
being lit, though.
I mean, the lighting, we can't
do it dynamically.
You can't move the
mouse around to
actual show the lighting.
But this is actually lighting
the tiles--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes, it is.
PAUL SAXMAN: --as it's
being loaded in.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think the fun
thing will be to share some of
the code and see what people
can do with it.
BRENDAN KENNY: Let's see if
I can draw those in here.
We might be able to do this.
Did that work?
There we go.
Yeah.
So this is not exactly the
most dynamic thing.
It's hard to tell, but
it's actually--
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
BRENDAN KENNY: Changing.
There.
PAUL SAXMAN: No, we
get the idea.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: There's some really
great imagery out there
from the high-rise camera.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so great
imagery, and we'll post the
code to split it up.
It's not great.
If there's any GDAL experts--
actually, we have some on our
team, so I might consult them
on how to get the higher
depth to the images.
But you can actually see one
of the problems with using
orthographic imagery
and lighting it.
I've lit it from below now, and
suddenly these mountains
look like they're--
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
They're embossed.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, embossed,
instead of
actually standing out.
And so there's lots of tricks
that we don't think about in
cartography that let you play
with your brain and take
advantage of your brain,
sometimes without you even
knowing until it looks terrible,
and people wonder
what's going on.
PAUL SAXMAN: So unfortunately,
today we're probably going to
take the questions offline.
But definitely post them if
you have any questions.
We're going to post the code.
We'll put that in either Stack
Overflow or follow up in some
of the comments that we have,
or in the Google+ or YouTube
comments, if you're looking
for something specific.
And--
BRENDAN KENNY: There we go.
That's better.
PAUL SAXMAN: Brendan, you're
still tweaking.
BRENDAN KENNY: Well, now
it's not operating so--
PAUL SAXMAN: And so hopefully
you guys can join us next week
or actually two weeks.
Brendan will be back.
And Brendan, Mano will
be around, too.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, in two
weeks we're talking about some
great HTML5 techniques with
Mano Marks, talking about
things like dragging a shape
file into the browser and
having it unfold on your map
right there without any server
intervention or anything
like that.
Yeah, just interesting ways of
displaying that kind of data,
your existing geographic data.
So join us then.
We'll make a post.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
All right.
And any comments you have,
post them, and we'll
definitely follow up.
Thanks a lot.
BRENDAN KENNY: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]